a fox news alert for you now the fda
just giving full approval to pfizer's
coping vaccine it's the first vaccine to
get that full approval and in record
time too that has critics asking if the
process was rushed was it well let's
bring in admiral brett gerard former
health and human services assistant
secretary and of course he was our
testings are so tell us a little bit sir
about what this moment means to get full
approval
well this is a very big moment in uh
operation warp speed history in the
history of our vaccines our fight
against the pandemic prior to this we
had emergency use authorization what
that really meant is that the public
health benefits outweighed the known and
potential harms what this says today is
we know the benefits we know the harms
and this vaccine is safe and effective
and every confidence can be given to
that americans should feel very good
even better than they did yesterday
about getting the vaccine yeah what took
so long
well it is a complicated process and i
know there are many many good
professionals incredible professionals
at the fda i was acting commissioner um
it does take a while because all the
data is looked at in detail you know
every page is turned the facilities are
inspected
however again as i've said before i
think it's unconscionable that the biden
administration does not have an fda
commissioner even nominated to provide
leadership it might have been a little
faster but it is complicated there's a
lot of material and americans should
feel very confident in the process some
have said that they were hesitant to get
the vaccine and point into this lack of
full approval and how do you think the
administration and its goal to try to
get more people vaccinated can utilize
this news
well i think the american people will
utilize the news the poll said about 30
percent of those who have not been
vaccinated would become vaccinated feel
very confident about that once the
vaccine received full approval that just
happened the vaccine is fully approved
and i'm very hopeful that this will
push people
over the edge to go get the vaccine
because it is
our best protection aside from natural
immunity
against all the hospitalizations and
deaths particularly that delta is
causing across the country admiral as
you look down the road now with the fda
approval and those talk every day now
about a booster shot requirement how do
you view that process today
so i i believe boosters will be uh
authorized at some point by the fda
hopefully soon uh the data in israel as
well as data in here are clear that our
vaccine immunity is very good but it
wanes over time so after five six seven
months our protection against infection
and particularly for those over 60
protection against hospitalization and
death decreases a booster shot just like
all your typical vaccines you know we
give them very many months apart we
don't give them all in one little
sequence so a booster shot for covid
would be very similar to booster shots
we get for other vaccines and really has
the potential to give many many years of
immunity so it's not just the number
it's the spacing so i'm i'm very
encouraged by the data out of israel uh
even published this weekend uh showing
that that third shot is highly
protective particularly in those over
six okay so just help us understand this
so in order to get the approval you need
time to make sure that it works right uh
just like the
the six-month pfizer vaccine let's say
followed by a booster perhaps if
necessary
but there were americans getting the
vaccine last december
so that's a full eight nine months ago
from today
so at what point would pfizer then
understand and know whether or not a
booster was necessary can you can you
forecast that
so uh pfizer has been talking about uh
waning immunity and there's been many
publications about waning immunity but
you have to have the time that goes by
and
six seven eight months this is the time
where the immunity wanes so you really
have to wait that amount of time
and what we're seeing right now is it's
not only waning immunity but the vaccine
is still effective against delta but
it's not as effective against delta as
the other variants in the and the and
the parent strain so what we're seeing
right now is because of diminished
effectiveness against delta and waning
immunity we're getting the cases and
that's why that third dose is going to
be very important it's already been
authorized for the immunosuppressed and
i am pretty certain it's going to be
authorized for at least people over 60
maybe over 50 within the next few weeks
we know that the efficacy goes down
maybe after eight months and especially
for people over 60. what do we know
about the uh lasting effects of natural
immunity
so natural immunity is is very important
and there are still no data to suggest
that vaccine immunity is better than
natural immunity i think both are highly
protective we do know however that even
if you're naturally immune
a dose of vaccine can even raise that
even further but i think you if you had
proof of covet infection
right now that's still equivalent to
vaccine immunity and even the cdc
recognizes that if you're an american
coming back to this country if you've
had a proof of a previous covet
infection you don't even need to be
tested so i think when businesses reopen
they ought to consider
natural immunity vaccine immunity or
frequent testing all equivalent to get
you back in the working place
um
i had one last quick thing which is um
some have suggested that uh you know
they'd like to go after big pharma
complain about big pharma and all of the
profits and that this is uh you know
suggesting a booster it's just a way for
them to make more money how would you
reply to that
um
look uh i'm not going to defend big
pharma except to say that they came to
the rescue with a lot of government
support here the doses are 20 bucks a
dose this is not very expensive um and
the science clearly says this is not a
pharma scheme this is absolutely
necessary to protect americans the first
two doses and now we see the third dose
okay the last point on this whole
booster thing
um you're gonna have some people are
gonna run to their doctor to get the
booster shot right i mean you can agree
on that you're gonna have somebody
saying you know man you told me to get
the vaccine i got the vaccine now i
gotta go back again
from a medical standpoint from a
messaging standpoint how do you
communicate that to people
that this is the next step that you need
to do to keep you and your family safe
well i i would just ask people to
consider when they get their children
vaccinated they didn't don't get all the
vaccines in one little bunch same thing
for hpv same thing for hepatitis b you
actually have to get it over time that
months should pass and your immune
system evolves its response and when you
get that boost it's long lasting i see
what we did here in the pandemic is we
got everybody vaccinated to to to
squelch the storm the fire but now we're
looking for that long lasting immunity
and the boost will do that